The general good experience.
It like fundamentally, there's two ways to think about security. One is, uh,
like computer security, uh, this idea that we'll somehow make computers secure,
we'll put information on the computers and then we'll prevent other people from
accessing those computers.
And that is like a losing strategy that people have been losing for 30 years.
You know, uh,
you information ends up on a computer somewhere and it ends up compromised in
the end. The other way to think about security is information security,
where you secure the information itself,
that you don't have to worry about the security of the computers.
You could have some computers in the cloud,
somewhere information is flowing through them and people can compromise,
compromise those things.
And it doesn't really matter because the information itself is encrypted. Um,
and so, you know, things like SMS, um, you know, the I message cloud backups,
um, uh, most other messengers, Facebook messenger, all that stuff, you know, um,
they're relying on this computer security model, um,
and that, uh, ends up disappointing people in the end.
Mm. And so you, why did you guys create it? Like what,
what was unsatisfactory about the other options that were available?
The way the internet works today is like insane. Uh, you know, that, uh,
you know, fundamentally, I feel like, um,
private communication is important because I think that change happens in
private, um, everything that is fundamentally decent today, uh,
started out as something that was a socially unacceptable idea at the time. Uh,
you look at things like, you know, obvious things that abolition of slavery,
legalization of marijuana, legalization of same-sex marriage, uh, even,
you know, constructing the declaration of independence.
Those are all things that required a space for people to process
ideas outside the context of everyday life. And, um,
those spaces don't exist on the internet today.
And I think it's kind of crazy the way the internet works today. You know,
that like if you imagined, um, you know,
every moment that you were talking to somebody in real life,
there was somebody there just with a clipboard,
a stranger taking notes about what you said that would change the character of
your conversations. Uh, and I think that in some ways,
like we're living through a shortage of brave or
bold or courageous ideas in part because people don't have the space to process
what's happening in their lives outside of the context of everyday
interactions. You know.
That's a really good way to put it because you got to give people a chance to
think things through. But if you do that publicly, they're not going to,
they're going to sort of like, like basically what you see on Twitter. You know,
if you stray from what is considered to be
the acceptable norm or the current ideology or whatever,
whenever you're supposed to,
whatever opinions you're supposed to have on a certain subject,
you get attacked ruthlessly. So,
so you see a lot of censorship and you also see a lot of virtue signaling where
people sort of pretend that they espouse a certain series of ideas because
that'll get them some, you know, some social credit.
Yeah, exactly.
I think that the communication in those environments is performative. You know,
you're either performing for an angry mob. You're performing for advertisers,
you're performing for, you know, the governments that are watching.
And I think also the ideas that make it through are kind of
tainted as a result, you know, that like, uh, did you watch any of the,
like the online hearing stuff that was happening over COVID, uh, you know,
where like, uh, city councils and stuff were having their hearings online? No,
I did not. Uh, it was kind of interesting to me because it's like, um, you know,
they can't meet in person, so they're doing it online. And, uh,
that means that the public comment period was also online, you know?
And so it used to be that like, you know, if you go to a city council meeting,
uh, they have a period of public comment where, you know,
people could just stand up and say, what do you think? You know? And like,
ordinarily, it's like, Oh, you got to go to city hall. You got to like,
wait in line, you got to sit there, you know, but then want us on zoom.
It's just sort of like, anyone can just show up at the zoom thing, you know,
they just dial in and then they're just like, here's what I think, you know?
And, uh, you know, it was kind of interesting because particularly,
uh, when a lot of the police brutality stuff was happening in Los Angeles,
I was, I was watching those city council hearings and, you know,
people were just like, you know, you know,
they were just calling you and be like, you. I yield the rest of my time. you.
You know, like it was just like a really brutal and, uh,
not undeservedly. So, and, uh, you know,
what was interesting to me was just watching the politicians basically,
you know, uh, who just had to sit there and just, they were just like it,
you know, and it was just like, you know,
you get three minutes and then there's someone else to get it, you know,
they're just like, okay. And now we'll hear from, you know, like since, and,
you know, watching that, you sort of realize that it's like, um,
to be a politician,
you have to just sort of fundamentally not really care what people think of
you, you know, uh, you have to fundamentally, uh,
just be comfortable sitting, you know, and having people yell at you,
you know, for three minutes and three minute increments for an hour or whatever,
you know?
And so it seems like what we've sort of done is like bred these people who were
willing to do that, you know,
and in some ways that's like a useful characteristic,
but in other ways that's the characteristic of a psychopath, you know? Yes.
And yes. And I think, you know, what we're seeing is that,
that also extends outside of those environments to do anything
ambitious today requires that you just are comfortable with
that kind of, um, feedback.
Like Trump's tweets, if you watch, you know,
if you look at Twitter and look at any of Trump's tweets,
when he tweets watch what people say, it's ruthless,
they go crazy. They go so hard and I'm, so I'm assuming he doesn't read them.
I'm assuming he just, or maybe he does. And just doesn't say anything.
He knows he doesn't go back and forth with people at least.
No, but, and I'm, I think, you know,
Trump is perfectly capable of just not caring, you know,
there's like people like, you know, grazing, it's just like, yeah, whatever,
you know, I'm the best they don't, you know? Yeah. And like, that's, um,
you know, that's politics, but I think, you know, the danger is when that, uh,
you know, to do anything ambitious, you know, outside of politics or whatever,
you know,
requires that you're capable of just not caring what people think or whatever,
because everything is happening in public.
I think you made a really good point in that change comes from
people discussing things privately, because you have to,
it's a, you have to be able to take a chance.
You have to be daring in and you have to be able to confide in people and you
have to be able to say, Hey, um, this is not right.
And we're going to do something about it. If you do that publicly,
the powers that be that do not want change in any way, shape or form they'll,
they'll come down on you. I mean,
this is essentially what Edward Snowden was warning everyone about when he
decided to go public with all this NSA information, he was saying, look, we,
this is not what we signed up for. You.
Someone's constantly monitoring your emails,
constantly listening to phone calls.
Like this is not this mass surveillance thing.
It's very bad for just the culture of free expression,
just our ability to have ideas and to be able to share them back and forth and
vet them out. It's very bad.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
I think when you look at the history of that kind of surveillance,
there are a few interesting inflection points, you know,
like at the beginning of, um, you know, the internet, as we know it,
and like the early to mid nineties, um,
that were these like DOD efforts to do mass surveillance, you know, um,
and, um, they were sort of open about what they were doing. Uh, uh,
and you know, one of them was this program called total information awareness.
Uh, and, uh, it was, they were trying to start this office, I think,
called the total awareness office or something within the DOD.
And the idea was like,
they're just going to like collect information on all Americans and everyone's
communication and just stock pilot into these, uh, databases.
And then they would use that to my mind, those things for information, uh,
it was sort of like, you know, their, their, uh,
effort to get in on this at the beginning of the information age. Uh,
and you know, th it was ridiculous, you know,
it's like they called it total information awareness.
They had a logo that was like, um, you know, the,
the pyramid with the eye on top of it. Oh yeah, this is, this is.
Their logo. It's like.
The pyramid with the eye, like casting a beam on the earth.
That bit of Latin there means knowledge is power. Oh, wow.
And interestingly, this program was actually started by, uh,
John Poindexter of all people who was involved in the Iran Contra and stuff,
I think really? Yeah.
And he like went to jail for a second and then was pardoned or something. But,
uh, so anyway, you know.
Was some up, these people are in charge of anything. I know, but what's also,
I just.
Kind of comical, is it like, they were like, this is what we're going to do.
Like.
You know, crazy. This is like this, this is our.
Plan, you know? And people were like, uh, I don't think so. You know, like,
I, this was like early mid nineties.
This authentication, biometric data,
face fingerprints gate, Iris, your gate.
So they're going to identify people based on the way they walk,
I guess your gate is that specific.
And then automated virtual data, repositories, privacy, and security.
This is fascinating because if you look at, I mean,
obviously no one thought of cell phones back then.
Exactly. Right. This is, so this is like kind of amateurish, right.
So it's like, they're like, this is what we're going to do. You know?
And people are like, ah, I don't think, you know, even like Congress is like,
ah, guys, I don't think we can like approve this, you know? Uh,
like you need a better logo, you know?
Yeah. For sure. But it's just this whole flow chart.
Is that what this would be? What do you, what do you call something like this?
What is called flow chart.
But yeah. Sort of designed to dazzle you in approving them.
It's like baffling to figure out what it is. Like, first of all,
what are all those little color tubes, those little ones,
those little cylinders, data.
Silos. Oh, that's the universal, they're all.
Different colors. There's purple ones. What's in the verbal data.
Gate or gate lives. Yeah. It's all princess information, but so,
okay. So that, you know, this, this stuff all sort of got shut down. Right.
You know, like they're like, okay, we can't do this, you know? Uh,
and then instead,
what ended up happening was like data naturally accumulated in different
places, you know, that, um, you know, like back then, if you had been, you know,
what they were trying to do is be like our proposal is that everyone carry a
government mandated tracking device at all times. Like, what do you guys think?
You know, it'll make us safer. You know? And people were like, no,
I don't think so. You know,
but instead everyone ended up just carrying cell phones at all times,
which are tracking your location and reporting them into centralized
repositories that government has access to, you know? And so, uh, you know,
this, this sort of like oblique surveillance infrastructure ended up emerging.
And that was what, you know, people sort of knew about, but didn't really know.
And that's what, uh, Snowden, um, revealed was like, uh, you know,
we don't have this instead. It's like all of that,
all of those things are happening naturally. You know, you're, you know,
Gates detection, fingerprint, you know,
like all this stuff's happening naturally, it's ending up in these places.
And then, you know,
governments are just going to those places and getting the information.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.